[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce petit
chemin qui sent la
noisette ce petit
chemin n' ni que ni
tête on le voit qui fait trois petits
tours dans le
puis il part au hasard en flamant comme
un lésard c'est le
rendez-vous de tous les
insectes les oiseaux pour
nous ils donnent leur
fête les lapin nous
invite souris-moi courant
vite ne Crais rien prend ma main dans ce
petit
chemin pour aller à la préfecture prends
la route numéro 3 tu suis la file des
voitures et tu t'en vas tout droit tout
droit c'est un billard c'est une piste
pas un arbre pas une fleur comme c'est
beau comme c'est triste nous ferons du
130 à l'heure mais moi ces routes
goudronn toutes ces routes me dégoûtent
si vous m'aimez venez venez venez
chanter venez Flammer et nous prendrons
un
raccourci le petit chemin que
voici et ce petit
chemin qui sent la noisette
se petit chev
m'a tourné la
tête j'ai posé trois
baisés sur tes cheveux
frisés et puis sur ta
figure toute barbe brouillée de mur pour
nous
observer des milliers
d'insectes CIT r assemblé
par-dessus nos
têtes mais un lièvre au
passage nous a dit soyez
SAG ne crains rien prend ma main dans ce
petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chemin merci Jean